he's pushing all right
because that's the other thing people
think well he's perhaps not pushing
what made me start thinking what made
him me start doing this was there was
this big guy in greece
and he was
he was beating everybody up in athens
he was a second down he was beating
everybody up
and um
he was quite a bully on the mat
and you can't get them and say
please don't train like i mean some
people would but i i'm not the sort of
person that say please don't train like
that
but so i had a conversation with him
asked him where he trains
a few questions
and he said oh it doesn't matter where i
go nobody can do i could arm me
so i said do you have a
ken he said yes i said get get your kent
and i done this
and i'm holding him like this and i go
are you pushing and i always remember he
was like this and his feet were skidding
on the mat
as he was trying to push
and at the same time he was looking at
me like that
thinking how are you doing that because
it's defying angles see there's no where
you is pushing
it's defying angles so your mind
can change the angle of a person
so if we um
i'm going to go through it all i'm just
trying to so have you come here
okay then you're here and i'm behind him
what i had to do was yeah you sit
comfortably if you want you can stay in
size or i don't mind it so
so what i'm doing is i mustn't go too
quick i must do that
over him but here i'm still connected
but only mentally
but can you feel can you feel something
because you can't see my hand
so he can't feel it so he doesn't know
but i as long as my mind is connected to
him
i don't need him to be connected to me
and i often say what i'm teaching you
two people must become one
and i'm the puppet of this person
you can't throw people without touching
them
like this you can't grow people without
touching them
if you want to dominate them
if my ego wants to dominate them you've
got to
you've got to go along
you've got to go along with them
so that was a physical movement this is
a
that's a much lighter movement
that's a much lighter again see each
time i'm doing it lighter and lighter
you see until because what i've done is
i've now got inside his mind but he
doesn't know i've got inside his mind
you see all we've really done is we've
become
attuned and you might see lots of
different teachers
but you might like
certain teachers
their charisma or just the way they
teach aikido or they do something
so stay there so when we get
um
and i do
or we do techniques like this
really
it's not done physically it's done
on a
mental level because what i'm doing is
i'm leading him
mentally
all right so i've learned how to
do this
mentally
so even though you're seeing the outside
results i'm going over here
over here
i'm going over here over here over here
he doesn't know
how it's being controlled
but
he's going there because
that seems to be the only thing to do so
all right
there's a dark side to this
as well as a good side and i've done
both because
when i was younger my ego wanted to
do it and get pleasure out of it
and then later on you sort of like work
out
i shouldn't be doing that
so there is yin and yang in my opinion
to this art
but oh sensei would do this
as he got older he
you know the
you would see the ikkyos
being performed
smoothly and easily but really is
but really he's not hardly touching them
so what i'd like you to do
is
take take your finger and your palm
okay
could be mine never as wrong in all the
years i've had it but
is it mine
no it might be mine
yeah it could be it never
jane is the only